Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show.
I'm Farron Cousins from a ring of fire sitting
in for David Pacman, but as I mentioned the
beginning of the show, David will in fact
be back on Monday with fresh content for you.
But for now, let's get right back to it.
Of course, one of the biggest things this
week was the Turning Point USA Conference.
And as we all know, one of the featured speakers
was Kyle Rittenhouse.
And when Rittenhouse emerged onto that stage,
it was basically like WWE right there.
He had his own theme song that they created
for him.
So if you haven't already seen the video?
Brace yourselves, because here is Kyle Rittenhouse's
entrance into that Turning Point USA conference.
Take a look at loud.
You know.
The crowd loved him, you heard chanting Kyle
Kyle.
But there was one person that was not happy
about this.
There was one conservative who understood
that maybe this isn't the best guy to be hoisting
upon our collective shoulders.
And believe it or not, folks, that person
happens to be Fox contributor Tomi Lahren.
On an episode of Outnumbered this week, Lahren
actually can't say she laid into conservatives
for.
Idolizing Kyle Rittenhouse, but she did question
why they're treating him like a rock star.
Here is what she had to say.
I do think that as conservatives, we need
to be a little careful when it comes to this.
I believe we can put up Kyle Rittenhouse as
someone who was innocent and was bullied by
and mistreated by the media.
But I think we should step back a little and
maybe not treat him like he's a rock star
or a celebrity.
I don't think that's necessarily a good look
for the conservative movement.
He did what he had to do.
He was defending himself.
Let's talk about self-defense.
Let's talk about the riots.
Let's talk about how everything went horribly,
horribly wrong that day.
But I think we should take a step back and
not make the man Bon Jovi.
But that's just my take.
She says.
Of course, that's how they're over.
That's just my opinion.
You know, don't don't kill the messenger.
Here's the thing.
She's right.
It's a weird thing to say, but Tomi Lahren
is right, and she's right for several reasons.
The first is.
What's he done?
Well, let's be honest, we all know what happened.
Two people are dead.
Kyle Rittenhouse was acquitted.
Now we could argue all day long whether or
not you think it was self-defense, whether
you think you should be here.
But those arguments no longer really matter.
OK?
Kyle Rittenhouse faced a jury.
He had his defense.
We had the prosecutors.
Defense prevailed.
Kyle Rittenhouse was acquitted.
That's the end of that, so we're not even
going to get into that.
But two people are dead.
And we know that he killed them, the court
says it's in self-defense, so we have to accept
that.
And now he's a hero.
Like now they're lifting him up.
They gave him a speaking gig.
Now I'll be perfectly honest with you, I don't
know what he said.
I didn't listen to it.
I have no interest in listening to it.
I don't care what he has to say.
Although we do know that he did say in an
interview after the acquittal that, you know,
people shouldn't be praising him for this.
I guess he's I guess he's OK with it now.
But either way, Lauren's point, I think I
don't want to put words in your mouth, but
I think what she's trying to get at is why.
What's the longevity?
Of Kyle Rittenhouse.
What is he actually doing to further the conservative
cause?
So the answer to that question would obviously
be nothing.
Not a thing.
And, of course, Turning Point is supposed
to be about these conservatives who are out
there making a difference, pushing their horrible
conservative policies on us, spitting out,
giving us new conservative talking points.
But that's not what Kyle Rittenhouse is, he's
not a political operative.
I mean, he's a kid.
He's a kid that's now gotten swept up into
all of this.
And honestly, I don't think he understands
it either.
I don't think he knows where he's going with
this.
Does he have a future in the conservative
movement?
Does Kyle Rittenhouse have a shelf life?
And that's the big point that Tomi Lahren
herself is attempting to make.
Think of it this way.
I pointed this out actually on fair and balanced
as well.
The McCloskeys right, the St. Louis gun couple.
We all remember them, right?
What are they doing now?
They were conservative heroes.
Heck, they had a speaking spot at the GOP
convention last year, where are they now?
Are they still these conservative rising stars?
I know I know the the guy was going to run
for Senate, and I don't think that went very
well for him.
I don't even know if that's still happening
because nobody cares about the McCloskeys
anymore.
And the same thing will eventually happen
to Kyle Rittenhouse.
You know, maybe, you know, there's gun rights
organizations will try to use him as a poster
child.
Maybe he'll do that.
Maybe he won't.
That's all pure speculation at this point,
to be honest.
We don't know what he will or will not do
with this newfound fame.
But one thing we can pretty much all come
to the same conclusion on is that based on
others who've been in this situation before,
the fame doesn't last.
The spotlights fade, they disappear and people
will forget except the families affected who
this individual is and they won't care anymore.
And I would like to think that that's what
Tomi Lahren was getting at.
But I also think there could be a degree of
jealousy there, right?
And let's face it, a couple of years ago,
Tomi Lahren was the it girl, right?
She was the one everybody was clamoring for.
She was the one making the headlines.
She was the one out there helping craft the
direction of the Republican Party.
A lot of people forgot she existed.
So maybe, maybe and this is, you know, to
to pull a layer, that's just my opinion.
Maybe she's a little jealous of having to
share the spotlight.
Maybe she's a little jealous that the spotlight
is not on her anymore.
You know, people have moved on.
And what's funny about that is I actually
said that many years ago when she first burst
onto the scene.
Because I have been in this business for going
on 18 years.
We have seen them come and go.
We have seen the fly by nighters, they make
a big pop, they make a big splash, they hang
around for a bit, sell a couple of books and
then they disappear.
They fade off into obscurity because the Republican
movement, you know, this conservative media
thing, it's always trying to find the next
hero, trying to find the next big thing, trying
to find the next pretty face in many instances.
And Tommy Star is fading.
Relegated to a weird show on Fox, having to
appear on a midday show to tell people that
it's a little cringeworthy what the Republicans
are doing with Kyle Rittenhouse.
Yeah.
Next stop is Hollywood Squares.
Maybe Dancing with the Stars and people will
have forgotten all about Tomi Lahren at that
point.
And that's, I think, what really scares her
the most.
Yes, conservatives should not be hoisting
Kyle Rittenhouse upon their shoulders.
But Tomi Lahren speaks from experience.
She knows what it's like as she knows how
much it hurts when you come crashing down
to reality